Il y a déjà plein de vidéos qui parle de Noël sur Youtube. Je vais pas moi aussi faire une vidéo qui parle de Noël. 'Fin j'ai un minimum d'originalité j'sais pas je...
Quand t'es petit, Noël c'est juste magique : la lumière dans la ville, l'odeur du sapin, le goût du pain d'épice...
... Et un chèque de ta grand mère ! Yeah, mamie !
Donne la Thune !
chaque année ¨, alala, j'ai trop hâte que ça arrive. Ah par contre j'avoue tous les ans c'est un peu une éternelle répétition il y aura la
rediffusion pour la 600e fois du père noël est une ordure
il y aura ce mec de ta famille que tu vois jamais de l'année sauf à noël
Sortez de chez moi, vous êtes qui ?
Bah je suis ton oncle... Ah oui c'est vrai, ça va Tonton? Joyeux Noël..
merci! Y aura ces fameux père noël de décoration qui grimpent les murs là franchement on dirait soit un mec cambriole chez toi ou
un pendu, hein, c'est vraiment glauque
ils vont essayer de nous vendre ces pulls de noël qui sont à la mode pendant deux semaines, à partir du 26 décembre
ils sont totalement périmés. Comme d'hab y aura ces gens qui gardent leurs sapins de noël trop longtemps même quand il a plus d'épines
on dirait que sapin il a fait une chimio quand sortira dehors il y aura cette ambiance de noël
inexplicable dans les films hein parce que moi dans mon quartier c'est plutôt ça
et vu qu'il ya une espèce de sapins qui s'appelle Nordmann moi comme chaque année j'aurai le droit des blagues à l'infini
Tu fais quoi là? bas je te mets une guirlande parce que t'es un sapin.. Norman!!
yes
Bon c'est bon, on a compris!
et comme d'hab y aura Gilles noël qui ramènera sa sciences.. T'sais à la base le père noël avant il était vert et maintenant il est
rouge à cause de coca? Ah ouais?
Et t'sais qu'aussi maintenant la petite souris elle est grise là, c'est à cause de Nike  - Non..
Oh j'ferme ma gueule, je suis bourré pu***
quand arrive la période de noël y a toujours un mec dans son entourage qui plaisante pas avec ça
pour lui Noël c'est vraiment très sérieux: - On est lundi je mange celui de mardi, on est pas à un jour près
jamais
tu les manges
dans l'ordre on recommence ! - Bon 23h30 qu'on peut ouvrir les cadeaux non? - Jamais!
on ouvre les cadeaux à minuit ok? -Bon ya assez de décorations de Noël comme ça, je vais ranger le carton je pense
jamais tu accroches toutes les bottes à la cheminée! - on n'a pas de cheminée.. -Ah bah au radiateur
on n'a pas de radiateur non plus
au grille-pain
Bah on a pas de grille pain
à un briquet alors. Attend mais c'est quoi sa motivation à ce mec? je comprends pas la..  ok patron, le calendrier de l'avent
c'est réglé, au niveau de la déco on est bon
on sera prêt pour le 24. Très bien Michel continue comme ça et tu finiras chef lutin
Et oui j'ai une voix de merde
et alors je suis le père, je t'emmerde. Quand tu es petit tes cadeaux ils sont un peu magiques
ils sentent noël, tu sens qu'ils sont conçus par des petits lutins au pôle nord dans le site du père noël
alors que quand tu es grand ah c'est plus pareil
bon une tringle à rideaux c'est le modèle de chez Ikea ça, celui qui est -10% à côté du rayon ampoule
comment tu savais que je voulais ça? - parce qu'on l'a acheté ensemble
Ah bah ouais
moi je ne comprends pas les gens qui dénigrent leur cadeau alors que tu es en train de l'ouvrir il gâche complètement le plaisir
bon voilà c'est trois fois rien j'avais pas d'idées
tout était fermé voilà je me suis pris un petit peu tard
mais tu peux aller changer... c'est bon ta gueule c'est l'intention qui compte ok
Bon bah je vais l'échanger.. -Ah oui les gens qui achètent des cadeaux à leurs animaux de compagnie c'est super mignon
par contre juste un truc le chat pour lui c'est pas noël c'est juste à mardi ou alors c'est juste
jour numéro 412 et un compte à rebours jusqu'au moment où il arrivera à l'enlever hein
faut surtout pas oublier qu'avoir des cadeaux à noël c'est vraiment une chance c'est même un luxe
les parents moi quand j'étais petit à noël il avait juste une orange d'ailleurs j'ai jamais compris pourquoi une orange pourquoi ce fruit en particulier
Woah un pamplemousse!
Ouais mon père est médecin
C'est vrai que maintenant les jouets pour enfants ils font totalement rêver
j'ai vu magasin de jouets ils vendent des drones moi quand j'étais petit j'avais un avion de chasse qui faisait tout
bruit lumière pilote qui parle démarrage au sol.. armement des réacteurs inférieurs. Ok tour de contrôle
dites à ma femme que je reviens ce soir qu'elle met la bouteille au frais. Quand à toi Billy, ce soir je te met ta branlée à la belote
allez accrocher vous, paré au décollage, ca risque de  secouer un peu..3, 2, 1
Sauf voler il voulait pas c'était un avion de chasse avec la fonction d'une voiture
à merde y'a pas l'option vol ça fait que rouler en fait
moi les gars on prend autoroute.. direction le carrefour market de porte de bagnolet let's go
Alors selon certains parents faut de dire toute la vérité sur le père noël aux enfants
c'est un point de vue je respecte ok mais est ce que dans ce cas là on dit vraiment tout aux enfants absolument tout
Tu vois timothée ce jouet il a été construit par un enfant taïwanais orphelin qui était payé 3 centimes par jour
Et lui à noël il a pas de cadeau à part l'ouragan mais ... *pleure*
bah ouais c'est pas compliqué de dire la vérité aux enfants.. Faut pas les prendre pour des cons
hein ma tcho
en tout cas le plus important à noël et ça vous le savez c'est être entouré des gens qu'on aime la famille les proches
alors pensez ce soir là plus que jamais à inviter les gens qui sont seul à votre table parce que passer noël tout seul c'est
vraiment la déprime moi je vous souhaite plein de bonnes choses merci pour cette année qui a été pour moi je crois la plus folle
10 millions d'abonnés voilà c'est ça mon cadeau je ne peux pas rêver mieux donc merci du fond du coeur
profiter au maximum de vos fêtes de fin d'année et puis surtout joyeux noël!
Il est minuit, on ouvre le champagne? Allez c'est parti
jamais à minuit c'est la messe de minuit
Bien joué Michel!
Vous êtes sur un téléphone alors appuyez de votre doigt sur ma grosse tête ici pour vous abonnez
facilement et en fait ça marche aussi depuis un ordi
alors elle est pas belle la vie